exams in wells and scotland have already
been cancelled for next year given the
ongoing uncertainty with coronavirus but
as things stand
pupils in england are still set to set
exams or they may be
slightly later than normal but is that
the right move well we can talk to the
chief inspector of ofsted the schools
regulator in england amanda spellman
thank you
very much for being on the programme so
should exams
be cancelled in england for this
academic year
we're all facing tough choices about
education at the moment there are some
important
lessons i think that came across from
last summer um we saw that um
young people very much um didn't like um
the the solution that was adopted and it
and ship
we shifted to awarding awarding the
grades that that had been put forward by
schools
but the what the message that came
across from young people was
their loss of agency they really really
didn't like
um not having the chance to show that
they can do better um than their than
their their
teachers um assess them at and
beyond that we know that the exam system
the syllabus is
those are the structures around which
upper secondary education is built and
if you take that away
um without having something to put in
its place
you make for a very difficult few months
for for many children and young people
as we saw
um last spring and summer for the all
those year 11s and year 13s
who suddenly weren't sure what they were
doing with their lives so it's a much
more difficult
thing than everybody thinks at the same
time of course
everyone can see that there are big
inequities
at the moment between different parts of
the country who knows how that picture
will develop over the next few months
so making sure that we get the right
paths the right opportunities
and the right catch up for every child
who's affected by but
by covid is of course really important
it's difficult though isn't it because
in part the chaos that happened last
summer
came because of the uncertainty is there
a risk that by
not saying now look we're just going to
not have exams this year
it risks further uncertainty more
u-turns more delays
more confusion in chaos we had the
certainty last year of no exams and i
think it's hard to say
that that that but that was a wonderful
outcome for children so i i know that
immense numbers of people are working on
this at the moment
working out what the best we can do to
create to create as much certainty and
as much good education
and good environment for children as we
can in
very difficult times i'm interested to
know how concerned you are
about data on the number of outbreaks in
secondary schools and specifically and
sage the government scientific advisors
say there'd been more than a thousand
outbreaks of coronavirus
in educational settings since schools
reopened in september
and in the second wave prevalence has
risen significantly
in school-aged children is this a worry
well of course there is a national worry
about um
rate rates rates of infection i think
it's very important to remember
um that kept that that we we never we
rarely know when a case is reported or
when cases are reported
where they happen what what we've seen
coming out of sage
at this stage i don't think says um that
everybody believes that
that schools are the biggest problem in
this in this pandemic
and of course the message that we've
been putting across from the reports we
published this week is how
extraordinarily high the damage
um to children can be when they're taken
out of all the normal structures and
systems
that help them develop look after them
for many months
um the educate not just the education
their personal development
can go backwards um their social skills
and of course that watchful eye that
teachers have for
the bigger things going wrong in
children's lives whether it's of medical
special educational needs or
sadly sometimes um abuse or neglect in
the family
all of those things add up to a really
really strong set of reasons why there's
a great deal
of advantage to keeping children in
school given
all the issues that you say given all
the reasons why it's so important for
children to be in school
how concerned are you about the fact
that so many children
are being sent home if there is a single
case
of covered in their year group for
example
and that so many people are missing
school as a result
i think we're seeing how hard it is um
to translate
guidance that shifts in difficult times
we know that health guidance
has shifted regularly we know that
schools are having to interpret getting
that balance right
of enough local flexibility without
leaving schools at sea is really hard
um so people can take the same guidance
and one school will
will will see that believe that it needs
to isolate
a handful of children another believe
that it needs to isolate a whole year
group
it is it's really really hard for
everybody working with it to get
the kind of consistency that a dream
world would hurt would we'd have
i'm hoping that we'll see more
as a more consistent picture emerging as
people get used to
to working with these restrictions and
these rules as you say it feels like the
guidance is just being
interpreted very differently by
different head teachers in different
schools
does there need to be more clarity and
in what sort of direction
it's it's such a delicate balance
between being
too so prescriptive that people can't
make it work within the varying the
varying circumstances and contacts
and leaving too much for the school i
know that people on each iteration
people are working taking taking
feedback trying to give
schools teachers parents um the clarity
in not the strong framework they all
need to do the very best for children
and just finally um universities the
government has
announced this travel window where
university students can return
back to their homes for christmas um we
saw of course
a spike in covered infections around the
time when universities went back
and covered rates in many university
towns above the national average
are you concerned that we're going to
see another spike
you're getting me off my patch there um
in terms of
public health and all i can say is that
is that for
all of us um we have to take we have to
take the advice that comes
and work and work within the
restrictions that are applying to us all
and it'd be quite wrong for me or
anybody else um to
to to argue about that and what is
important is
is is that we make sure that all sides
of the picture are seen and understood
and part of our job at ofsted is to make
sure that people understand
the impact on the children on whom our
work throws light
okay thank you very much for being on
the program always good to talk thank
you